en france comité d'accueil tout à
l'heure pour emmanuel macron à
saint-etienne un déplacement dans la
loire pour le chef de l'état dans le
cadre de son plan d'investissement
france 2030 une centaine de manifestants
et de membres de différents syndicats se
sont réunis devant la préfecture de la
cité stéphanoise pour s'opposer à la
politique du président parmi les
revendications le pouvoir d'achat ou
encore la hausse des prix de l'énergie
une délégation syndicale doit être reçue
par les conseillers des manuels macron
cet après-midi réaction de militants au
micro de luis carballo
partout où il se déplacera je pense
qu'il y aura comme ça des comités
d'accueil c'est plus un président c'est
un candidat est ce qu'en dit là il ya un
bilan très mauvais très très mauvais
notamment on va peut être pouvoir
d'achat je rappelle que le 5 octobre on
était déjà des dizaines de milliers en
grève en manifestations dans la rue pour
dénoncer la situation faite aux salariés
tout a augmenté et sauf que et bien les
salaires
non pas les salaires et les retraites et
les minima sociaux n'ont pas suivi pour
autant il y en a qui ont bien profité de
la crise puisque les entreprises du cac
40 ont fait des profits comme jamais sur
le premier semestre ces 57 milliards
d'euros de dividendes ont été versés aux
actionnaires donc de l'argent et on en
est ce que réclame la cgt s'est
effectivement qu'ils soient répartis
d'une autre manière et c'est ça que nous
voulons faire entendre au père de la
république aujourd'hui à mais il est
complètement catastrophique le bilan de
macron
ccc juste le rôle que le rouleau
compresseur social qui continue
d'avancer et
et voilà nous on essaie d'y mettre un
frein quoi en se rassemblant et en se
mobilisant message que l'on souhaiterait
faire passer c'est celui du manque de
moyens
nos écoles monde de moyens qui est connu
qui est
qui s'amplifie d'année en année qui
commence à devenir vraiment très
problématique pour les conditions
d'apprentissage nos d'élèves